let's go back to the olympic games so i
get up in the olympic
in the morning and i'm not sure when the
weigh-ins were but
i think i was probably a pound over
uh you know and that's about a half a
kilo 1.1 pounds
is a kilo because we wouldn't kilograms
so what do you do with that pond you're
right
no i just i just went over to the they
had a sauna there
and i got in the sauna and the and the
funny thing was the morning of
the of the of the finals
there was there was another athlete in
the sauna
and american or no it was a european
i don't remember where she was from i'm
not a russian well you know what i kind
of think
it was a plot because it was a girl
interesting and she didn't have her top
on oh wow
and that was pretty common and so you
know it's kind of interesting
you you think back about it because
there's some funny things that that go
on
behind the scenes in olympic games in
world games
anytime when you have country against
country and so there's some crazy stuff
mine goes on yeah did any of it affect
you
did you was there any well i almost
stayed too long in the sun
you lost you lost a little bit over i
lost a little more in a pound yeah
but uh but it didn't really bother me
because i wasn't like
i wasn't like cutting a lot of weight so
so
you